we're also watching closely the twitter
feed of the transport secretary
grant shaps who says data shows we now
need to remove
portugal minus the azores and madeira
hungary
french polynesia and reunion from the
travel corridor list to keep everyone
safe so if you're arriving in england
from these destinations
after 4am on saturday you will need to
self-isolate for 14 days he says
he says through enhanced data we now
have the capability to assess
islands separate to their mainland
countries so that's why
the azores and madeira are
exempt from this self-isolation for 14
days but portugal not
though he adds this week sweden has been
added to the travel corridor list so if
you arrive in england from
sweden uh the transport secretary says
you will not
need to self-isolate for
14 days so portugal
minus the islands added to
the list